sometimes watching a movie just isn't
enough you also want to eat that movie
and that's why there's movie recipes
today we're going to show you how to
make a Great Gatsby cocktail that is a
cocktail that tastes exactly like the
movie The Great Gatsby The Great Gatsby
cocktail is a frozen cocktail to
replicate the icy cold New York City the
movie presents so you'll need some ice
cream now you want to find the most
pretentious ice cream flavor you can for
my purposes today I want with a chai tea
and chocolate ginger cookies now you may
not have that exact flavor in your local
grocery but just walk down the ice cream
aisle and read the flavor names to
yourself when you get the one that makes
you want to punch someone in the face
you found your ice cream next we need a
liqueur because this is a cocktail not a
milkshake we're gonna go with Gentleman
Jack because it's classiest just like
Great Gatsby and also because Leonardo
once played a character named Jack and
Titanic another movie that was also
classiest
The Great Gatsby is ultimately about
Leonardo DiCaprio's heartbreak so we
need some Leo tears now those aren't as
easy to come by as you might think but
fortunately artificial tears are close
enough to give us the same effect the
secret ingredient is a healthy dose of
old Sports seasoning now do not skimp on
this people you need lots of that
finally garnish with a lit cigarette and
enjoy mmm Gatsby
Oh